I said this is boy-crazy oh my several
times cry never do that yeah that what I
don't care what dipper goes to Taco Bell
is like doubt nothing does I'll cream
for that but done this episode hit Lant
fucking zealand's bass it clearly has a
really good sense it lance bass or bass
doesn't matter um it doesn't him uh
I doubt even Maris day and he's like
guerre I don't care you know and he was
cloned I mean out of a tank so uh I'm
really shocked Disney did this episode
really considering their propensity for
crew Jonas Brothers and stuff yeah I
mean that's why it's I would expect it
from something like South Park who
doesn't have to give a fuck but Disney
uh the only thing I can figure is that
they were obviously more satirizing like
NSYNC and the Backstreet Boys and stuff
so maybe they're just like yeah no no
that's what it is that's what it is and
I'm a Disney just has a really good
sense of humor I don't know but this is
an episode where uh Mabel and her
girlfriends ago to see this band called
several times like I said they're in
that boy's world uh whatever that was
the manga yeah yeah and um goo and it
turns out that they actually are as all
of us thought cloned and manufactured
and so on and so forth
maple discovers it frees them keeps them
locked away kind of like et teaches them
about the world because I never been in
the world she's the one who puts pizza
in our trough it stops them from
honestly there's a lot of lives I
remember from this one just because I
thought them making fun of the boy band
was so funny their inability to do the
suppose of things well I like someone
who changes our new space it's like Oh
God
and they all have like the same eyes too
which I like a Serb big bug blue blue
eyes um and she gets obsessed wants to
keep them finally realizes it's not the
right thing to do let them go uh and
then there's a subplot going on with um
uh dipper trying to break up Wendy and
Robbie for a good reason because he's
been using the CD that has a subliminal
message uh I'm almost wondering there's
some I mean like
the case was some sort of weird
supernatural case or maybe that's just
like his design but I don't think he's
talented enough to have a CD case like
that so I'm wondering where he got it
from uh the night of the Necronomicon
yes or the Necronomicon I don't want
that I fuckin hate that character next I
don't want this um so they're officially
broken up which is like thank you hey I
want see he comes back like in one more
episode I think in it's very minor all
right yeah I hate that characters never
likable I'm so glad you realized
something
watching the previous episode or maybe
was the one before that maybe the life
guard episode but I actually don't mind
Wendy when she's away from her freaking
friends yeah the characters fine when
like the king away from Robbie
especially like the characters I don't
even mind that much is marginally Carens
that much but like I yeah like I don't
mind the characters whenever he shows up
or whenever her friends show up like
that's when they kind of annoy me like
but alone she's fine
ya know and she's got some good moments
especially in the second season that um
but yeah so there's a subliminal message
that they try to uh break away
you know her and him and get away from a
scumbag and that dipper immediately
tries to go in from a move in which is
uh she's like what the hell's wrong with
you runs away which is like yeah that
was pretty douchey differ
um but still understandable for that age
it's like well he's gone now that's
really you want me right cuz here you
men are so selfish and I'm just like
well he's 12 but but I guess a good
lesson for him to learn and stuff um and
yet I realized there was no like she
doesn't come back and is like you know
hey let's talk right they like it does
her they love it yeah which I like again
just an packing up more pockle it more
grunkle Stan moments finally a
legitimate reason to punch a teenager
it's a population think that was my
favorite Oh lousy beautiful men eating
out of my trash wait what
um Mabel kicks the boyband out run away
like dogs
and the best line at all there's as soon
as they run away they're feeling good
like they won't last a week um so yeah
the only other thing I noticed outside
the CD was the I'm wondering if that
goat that's I know it sounds weird but I
went that go plays a part in anything
cuz it shows up in every episode well
okay running gag its eyes are very
strange they're like alien eyes and I'm
really wondering if somewhere like
they're gonna do something with that um
and it eats licensed place why would eat
a license plate
um but yeah so it's uh like I said I
loved the mocking of the whole boyband
thing um especially like it's a with
feds Disney doing this this was one that
uh you know my wife was working on
something when I put this on and she
glanced and she's like Disney make this
like really don't act like the Jonas
Brothers and stuff I was like yeah
whatever it's like a secrecy this shows
making us cash so um okay I got you
you've been fuckin hypocrite
well obviously they have a good says it
you were now so no we don't they just
make us money um but yeah I like I said
I I'm just so impressed that they're
just like yeah we're fine with this go
for it it's it's it's funny it's fine so
um yeah definitely give them a lot of
credit for that uh yeah it's a it's a
good episode it's got a lot of funny a
lot of funny lines and uh keeping a too
much else
um yeah it's just funny
you got a they I I think I mentioned
most of the things I like so the boy
bands in particular we're just hilarious
yeah uncle grunkle Stan spit-take - let
me just sip this here for the spit take
and that wasn't spit work um ya know
just very amusing
mmm it's tight girl it's tight dang oh
and kissing the tree dangle girl oh I
know what I forget uh the message at the
end you should start off with that uh
apparently says are you happy now Ariel
which is like what
apparently Ariel is the day
of the sister of the creator but that's
still weird so the only thing I can
figure maybe she liked boyband I guess
yeah it's or or hated boy bands or hated
boy yeah it could be either one really
yeah some a she just wanna pass out like
you know we make fun of those boy bands
for God's sake um either in a positive
way or take it away I don't know but
maybe that's part of it too is that even
though they're pretty dumb they're still
so naive and innocent like maybe that's
sort of how they get away from the two
because it doesn't seem like overly
mean-spirited it seems more like you
know we just don't know any better
they're like a little kid I guess
honestly it was implying that they're
basically a bunch of mindless gerbils
like seems being spirited to me but okay
so you hate gerbils that's what you're
saying
who doesn't I'm hearing a lot about you
today
cray cray